marca samedi citez-moi deux chefs du
jury de top chef 2010 9 et jesse oui
trop tard il y avait les darroze michel
ça veut dire accord studio radio vous
rappelle qu'il a eu un petit problème au
niveau des poignets du pub c'est
peut-être c'est la boule rouge qui l'a
fait déséquilibrer bien entendu la boule
lula l'a fait sortir mais non tu as mal
répond à malabo ne gardait pas
dilatation reprend l'europe en attention
quel type de bowser permet à un jury de
la france a un incroyable talent
d'envoyer un faux dit dans le vert deux
catalyseurs oui gilles verdez attention
gilles verdez vrai ou faux passe-partout
essayer de participer à ce vote skid row
l'embrasser sur quatre sur quel canal de
la tnt se trouve la chaîne public sénat
puis senna je sais pas alors dites
jamais alors vite et l'a13
l ancien proche de benjamin castaldi
présentait l'émission nice people en duo
avec arthur en 2003 sur tf1 appelé
flavie flament